this podcast and all other podcasts on
my channel are brought to you by our
supporters on patreon if you would like
ad-free unedited and early versions of
podcasts you can sign up at patreon.com
charolanazard where we also release
extra content and support the creation
of new shows hello everyone i'm alana
and welcome to another episode of video
game writing 101 today i am joined by
ian and ryan would you guys like to
introduce yourself ian who are you
hi uh my name is ian milton polly uh i
work with frognation on the soul series
as a translator how about you ryan
um i my name is ryan and i have
been working with frog nation a little
bit longer than ian and uh i i too have
worked on the
from software games and ian came along
around dark souls 2 right uh dark souls
1 dlc yeah the dlc dark souls thank you
for reminding me
how many years has it been for you for
me um
10 years now
about 20 20 years so you guys enjoy it
then apparently like that's a long time
to stay at one place
love it yeah um so i really wanted to
chat to both you since i started doing
this podcast it occurred to me that like
the one piece of
video game writing that i know almost
nothing about is localization i know
very very very little um i know that for
the longest time i thought it was just
translation and then i slowly learned
the importance of like understanding
context
it's not a direct translation is kind of
what i mean yeah localization is
basically good translation in my mind
but yes
so what goes into your job like what is
what actually is the day job what do you
what do you have to do what's the basic
way to describe it to people who have no
idea what you do
well if you play video games
uh you'll notice that they're a lot like
movies nowadays
and so there's a lot of dialogue and
there's lots of characters and there's
lots of narration
and there's lots of stories there's also
lots of menus if you can imagine for all
the weapons and guns or whatever
you might need to tell somebody so they
can play their game and we do all of the
language
we we do japanese games we turn them all
into english
so we get files while they're making the
game that have text
and we have to translate it
that involves a lot of
finding out the context what's really
happening so that you don't make silly
mistakes
um
that are very possible uh translation is
not enough in like very practical terms
it's a lot of looking at excel
spreadsheets
and you know talking in like a a slack
or slack style program i mean
10 years ago it was just emails you'd
just be emailing each other imagine that
like what do you think about this
translation is this right can we figure
out what so it's like a lot of back and
forth as you're trying to get
interesting i guess like you mentioned
needing context for stuff and that's
something that i had absolutely really
considered so how yes how do you
approach that say i give you an item
in english um
or in japanese and you need to translate
it to english does that go through a
process of like what does this item do
what is the context of it where is it in
the world like it's a lot more
complicated than just
getting the text
well i mean all those things are super
important but uh are things that can
also change during the course of
development so the dialogue is much more
continual um you know we have these
mechanisms where you know we have a
translator working on the text and you
know we have editors uh and those will
be like
uh for in frognation's case both like um
japanese native speakers and english
native speakers checking the text
afterwards
and also we have a fairly robust system
for asking the devs what their
intentions are
um
you know in in the wider sort of
translation world it will really depend
on the project whether you
uh have
how much access you have to the game
while it's in development um these days
with security being like such a key like
factor in everything it's much harder to
get
um hands-on especially in this sort of
like
decentralized uh sort of pandemic world
that we're living in now yeah um
but it seems like from specifically for
obvious reasons takes it very seriously
um
so i imagine i'm not going to ask you to
speak at length about any of those
systems but i imagine that for you guys
it's super collaborative the whole way
through working on a game like dark
souls so um the you know uh miyazaki
will have the final uh has the final say
on what he really thinks will work
and uh we're just like
expert consultants who uh work with him
and try to come up with
uh we give him a lot of candidates uh
ian comes up with a lot of the names
and uh
they're usually all excellent names
sometimes just some second tier names
and uh
he goes over them and uh
tries to figure out one that will fit
what he's imagining as well so it's a
lot of fun i mean
i don't i would never no i don't worry
about um
what people are going to think about it
because you know i think it's good
you're just worried about making
something good that is my answer too
when people like you how are you worried
about writing something good
yeah but only insofar as the studio is
concerned in the immediate you know like
that's you can't think about what
everybody thinks about all of that stuff
but yeah do you have any this is the
question that i've been trying to uh ask
uh everybody that i get on the show do
you guys have any
um favorite moments from your time
localizing like anything not even just
drum stuff like favorite things about
your job or things that you like
particularly love that people might not
necessarily expect well
um
you sort of remember peaks
and
um when we were working on um when i was
working on solaire
for uh dark souls i was
really excited about how it was all
sounding and then when we recorded it i
was really uh amazed at how the actor
handled it
and then
and that was great i was just like very
satisfied and um
sort of hoping that people will enjoy it
and then when it exceeds expectations
and he becomes like a meme and people
are saying raise the sun and stuff
that's that's kind of definitely a peak
for uh you know for
enjoyment did you see that football
player
uh there was a football play nfl player
who recent recently went viral
um for doing praise the sun oh my god
wow yeah and there's like all these
video clips of of like you have to see
yeah it's like he was trying to do it as
his touchdown celebration and he'd do
this and was like it's probably too
niche people don't know what i'm doing
but obviously they did because it went
viral
it's very cool
that that is amazing yeah i have to see
that yeah i mean that's the kind of
thing you're talking about i guess do
you oh that's wicked yeah do you have
any that stand out to you ian
um i don't know about anything quite so
granular as that i mean i don't know i
came into the series as a fan like the
whole reason um like i applied to frog
nation was because i had played demon
souls like uh before it even came out in
in europe or america i imported like a
like a korean copy
um and just just for for the sake of
history
i have a
honestly ian i
you know i'm i think about things and so
if you were
sharp and you are
i suspect
that you must have found some criticize
some translations of mine to criticize
in order to prove that you could do this
no i didn't have to at all i just i was
just really nice about it
it was so it was so unique at the time i
mean
um
you know it was it was a world pre-game
of thrones where there were very
different expectations around fantasy
and you know as as a as a younger man i
as a teenager really i used to get
really frustrated with like the um
the standard for sort of
grand fantasy within like
you know within film and video games
generally having like american accents
and you know teenage british stomping
his feet being like but they wouldn't
have spoken like that
you know it sounds very unnatural to me
as well yeah uh you know
i mean i'm much less cut and dry about
that kind of thing now uh you know there
are some great some great stuff around
and like the needle has moved so much on
that stuff that it's actually kind of
refreshing a lot of the time um but
anyway yeah i basically was just like i
really like the vibe of this game um
the work that you guys did with the with
the actors with the sort of the very
much like lower key performances
compared to a lot of games um it really
struck a chord with me that sort of um
sparse sort of elegic world um and so i
was like well i i really admire this i
would love to to get involved um
and you know my my tack was that
you know i i hadn't really done much
by way of translation at that point uh
really nothing so i i sort of
propositioned um
the company as like well maybe i could
just like do some light editing and
learn the ropes and that's how i went
forward really so basically it was like
you liked
dark souls and then you reached out
to frog nation from from there that's
kind of how you yeah well so yeah i i
really like deep inside sorry um so yeah
so it was about the time that dark souls
it was um it was the year the dark souls
was going to come out that i was
applying and i started working with frog
nation on like some smaller projects and
by the time it came to the dlc i had
proven myself well enough that they were
like okay you can edit this and
obviously i was terrified so i basically
just tried to sort of mesh in with what
was already established around the world
um and the the style that was already
established in those games uh and and
pretty much for for dark souls 2 as well
yeah
so bloodborne was really the first one
for me that uh i was confident enough to
to really feel like i had sort of
value of my own to add
sort of confidently you know it's part
of the the same legacy of games but it
was a new ip so it was like
very exciting in that regard for me so
that like experience as a whole it's
kind of like the first real highlight of
my career i would say great game it's
not a bad place to start
yeah i love that
it is time to talk about the second
annual video game accessibility awards
brought to you by pizza hut a very big
thank you to ign for helping out to
reveal our nominees if you didn't
already know the show is set to air on
march 12th at 2pm pt hosted by me and
steven spahn and we have just revealed
our nominees the categories are ability
to bypass
clear text
improved precision
input reduction
remapping
second channel
training grounds
ai assistance
and peer assistance
if you want a little bit more
information regarding what these
categories mean exactly you can check
out the post that's up on ign right now
or otherwise tune in to the show itself
where we will be explaining what these
things are and why video game
accessibility is so important again a
huge thank you to our partners at
ablegamers real good touring and pizza
hut for making the show possible this
year we are so excited for you all to
see it and very excited to announce some
of our literal celebrity guest
presenters when the 2021 video game
accessibility awards as on march 12th
2022 now back to the video so ian when
we first went to london to record demon
souls on like a shoestring budget
we didn't
understand miyazaki's vision yet either
because we could really couldn't see it
until the game was absolutely finished i
played it on a debug debug console but
it
i did i didn't think it was a good game
until it was done
and
um uh we went to london to record it and
in the studio it was like every day all
day i kept translating from miyazaki to
tell that voice actor softer
less emotion low-key
there's really there's not huge range
it's it's
everything's sort of dark and somber in
this world and you have and
and trying to get and and i'm like
this is going to be rather low-key but
we'll see and of course it totally
meshed with with the whole game and so
it was perfect
um but that was part of what um ian
noticed about the
yeah i wonder if people are expecting to
go in and
do like a sort of more exaggerated anime
style and maybe that's
why they're defaulting to being more
like performative i don't know and then
and then you're like convincing them to
reign it in which you're right is like
in a really specific direction that i
had never considered is consistent
throughout from some games but it works
very very well yeah well i mean they've
expanded the range in many ways uh you
know visually and
with the emotions as well but for demon
souls and for bloodborne in its own way
it was kind of a
cohesive uh kind of
constant um
single kind of color
uh and so in a way i think demon souls
and bloodborne you can really kind of
uh
i think this kind of a euphoria when
they're just when you're just we just
like been playing it for hours and
you're totally like
um
enmeshed in this in this
dark world there's something um i think
there's something strangely euphoric
about the the bleakness of it i totally
agree complete especially with
bloodborne i completely agree um so we
touched a little bit there on how ian
got started and i know we spoke about
this earlier ryan but how did how did
you get started how did you get involved
okay so as a
as a in grade school in seattle
i watched robotech and star blazers as a
kid
i freaking loved it and i noticed at the
end that they were very
foreign names that were maybe chinese
later find out they're japanese
and i remembered that
and then i forgot all of that because
they weren't we weren't importing any
quality japanese
material in the interim but when i was
15 i found
akira um hell yeah
and it was in japanese but i watched it
a hundred times nevertheless
uh
about 90 of those times was to convert
somebody because you know you have to
know how
how amazing this new
animation coming out of japan is that
nobody knows i still do that with akira
so i think you'll find
well yeah a lot of people a lot of
people did like it um i feel like i had
a small hand in um
the spread of japanese anime yeah uh on
the west coast at least because i had so
many people who got into it and like
went on to like a university to like
start the anime club there and
etc etc that's awesome
yes and um
so so i come back at age 15.
um i'm like this is kind of like the art
style looks like the stuff i was
watching as a kid car blazers and
robotics so that's this is this is
amazing but it's in japanese oh well so
i had i mean i was just so taken aback
by it that i just i i had no choice but
to learn japanese so i started self
teaching myself with a dictionary and i
don't know the order of
the words so i look at a word and i just
searched the whole dictionary beginning
because there's no there's no
it's just i have nothing to go off at
that point the first name the first word
i tried to look up turned out to be a
proper noun a name of a woman
and it was not in the dictionary but i
figured it out eventually
so
i
did a lot of japanese
uh university
uh grad school and then i
had no idea what i wanted to do
but i had
gone through
hundreds and hundreds of japanese
animated films and tv series and read
comics and played games i used to play
chrono trigger with a dictionary
and a pad of paper and my rule was that
i would not even though i wanted to
progress through the game quickly as a
gamer my rule was that i wouldn't i
wouldn't go until i figured out what
each word was so i'd look up every word
of course
my cousin actually learned to speak
spanish through playing assassin's creed
fully in spanish similarly and it worked
she could speak spanish now nice very
nice
yeah
i took uh i absorbed a lot of stuff like
that and so i was good at japanese but i
had no desire to work i can't relate
and then uh i found i i wanted to get
into translation and i want to do
translation of games or anime or comics
and it turned out the games was the one
where they actually paid people to do it
and so
i started doing the games and that
picked up very quickly at the time
you could do
you know i did a couple jobs well and
then i just started getting
more and more requests so it kind of
went on from there which is about 99
1999.
i feel like probably part of what helped
you was the area that you started in
like surely there are a lot more people
doing it now
there are a lot yeah now i'm amazed by
the great number of
uh foreign people here who are speaking
japanese quite amazingly um so i'll yeah
there was less competition
uh also it's interesting to note that if
i had been a few years later i may have
just
gotten my japanese animation fix with
all the great subtitles subtitled the
material that came out shortly
thereafter in my time we didn't have it
we had like
two releases per year so there's like
no availability so you just you just had
to learn japanese or you had to read
about what the plot was and share the
info with your friends and stuff and
watch it as you recall the plot and
stuff like that it's like a real
butterfly effect thing of like the
things that could have gone differently
in your life if you weren't watching
anime in that era that's super
interesting
but yeah i mean i fell in love with
japanese pop culture and then i fell in
love with japan
um
and it just went from there uh
lynn robson at frog nation contacted me
to do some sony work and so i've been at
frog nation working on
uh just a whole bunch of stuff for two
decades that's amazing
yeah um so obviously things have changed
since both of you started i feel like
but do you have any advice for people
who might be interested in getting into
localization like what's a good place to
start
i'm also getting tough questions i know
well the problem i i guess it's it's
like a lot of these industries which you
know don't have like a grad program it's
yeah like everyone feels like they're
very like sort of just fortunate in
their circumstances like right time
right place i mean i certainly felt that
way definitely
um like i mean i i didn't even go into
learning japanese with the express
intent of becoming a translator it was
just something that always interested me
as an aspect of games um
like you know i i i was a kid in the 90s
and reading these magazines which would
like
absolutely go wild over like these
japanese gems that like never made it
over here and i had very much sort of
like an indie music mentality of like
once you know all the most hardcore
stuff
um
all the good rarities um
and you know other than that also like
uh
i don't know i feel like translation was
kind of
uh sort of embedded within me at a very
early age because i i have a i had an
english dad but um
a thai mother and my dad spoke no thai
um and so when he would try and interact
with my family either my mum or i would
have to like interpret for him so i was
sort of doing that from a very young age
sort of
considering the world sort of between
two languages yeah um
so
it was it was sort of like uh you know i
wanted to work in games so and i i had
picked up the skill of japanese um
and just wanted to use it and sort of
tried my luck what i will say is i think
like a lot of these industries you've
got to try and create your own chances
so just you know try and be proactive
about applying to places um also
you know um i i would say personally uh
i feel like you know you've got to know
the source language well but you've also
got to be really good in your target
language so like don't don't neglect
sort of keeping up with uh
you know the the good the good culture
that is coming out in in your own like
home language because uh you need to
keep sharp on it like you need to turn
out a good sentence at the end of the
day yeah um the less work you're making
for the other people working on the
project in terms of editing stuff yeah
like a better significant portion of
your job is writing a good sentence in
english and making sure it makes sense
it's not just like translating it's
certainly a lot more complicated than
that you also have to be good english
writers to be able to do it i never
considered that but you're absolutely
right that makes sense yeah i mean
i i
i studied english literature at
university you know and i i kind of
drifted more towards medieval stuff at
the end so it set me up pretty well for
working on these games you know yeah
definitely yeah i'm
i guess uh do you ever spend much time
writing in in english like
in terms of a hobby or
is it just something that you largely do
for work
it's something that i would actually
like to do a lot more but when most of
your day is already putting words onto a
page then it can be a bit tiring to
continue that as a hobby so not as much
as i'd like but yeah
it's strongly agreed
i feel like most video game writers say
that how about you ryan do you ever like
just do any writing in your spare time
uh no um i but it's like that it's like
i have the same feeling it's like i wish
i i wish i'd yeah it more like maybe uh
you know i'll never retire but if i if i
retired i'd want to write i mean i i'd
like to i'm always thinking about
something that i could write that would
really be that would really be
meaningful that only i could do i
haven't found it yet um
i did write for a i do a lot of mahjong
i did write for a japanese mahjong
magazine for about 10 years japanese
which was a great experience um that's
cool
so i've done i've done writing i mean
i've done
i've had the chance to write um a scene
here there for things
um
if you've seen uh starship troopers five
which is quite unknown because i have
pewter graphics and it's made in japan
okay
i wrote the love scene for that one so
cool
um and it was well received actually it
was the at least the love scene
um
but i'd like to do more
um
but you know uh
if you've read daniel kahneman on the
think fast think slow the type two brain
you can only really focus
and concentrate and do something like
translation for like maybe five hours a
day really well so
your time does run out no i totally get
that yeah i mean jumping off of that um
what are some of the
unexpected challenges that you both have
to deal with just doing your jobs like
what are some of the things that are
especially hard that people might not
expect
well i have
uh one answer to that that happened
somewhere along the way
where i've
determined that
clients don't always know
[Music]
what constitutes a good translation
that's one of the reasons that they're
hiring you
but sometimes a client will
[Music]
wonder
why
they'll notice something
and we're talking about japanese clients
a lot of japanese have
some
every japanese person has some english
education some more than others
but some clients would um
would recall their their english
knowledge and they would say like you
know why isn't
this word being translated like this or
why isn't what how did one sentence
become two
and
uh instead of being like because it's
the best way to do it um yeah that
doesn't really go down that well in a
meeting
instead of doing that you have i had to
tell myself that i need to
um
i need to explain this really well i
need to defend
the translation i need to um
educate the client so that they know
that this is this is fine and that it
works for the xyz reasons so
having to be
patient with somebody who's not a words
they're not a wordsmith
they're paying you to do it but
sometimes they they can be like
a lot some alarm signal goes some some
bell goes off and they're worried about
something and so
you may have to spend time on um
discussing things to to to educate a
client yeah you're right i would not
have guessed that that was part of it
because you would think that people
would just be like you know better than
me but it makes sense that patience is
part of every job just in a different
degree
um but especially when you're the one
who knows both languages but everyone's
probably like i know i could speak
english
like that is super complicated i feel
like especially you know with
colloquialisms i feel like that's such
an interesting part of localization
is
figuring out
how a turn of phrase works and maybe
your client isn't familiar with like
what this weird colloquialism means in
japanese verses in english how do you
approach stuff like that where there's
like just absolutely no direct
translation from japanese to english
there's nothing that exists is that the
kind of instance where you'll split
something into two sentences
uh that would be
yes i mean splitting things into
different numbers of sentences can
happen all the time um that's just like
par for the course reshuffling yeah
yes sometimes the order has to be
reversed for a thought in order for it
to to to work well in english um
you know japanese grammar is essentially
reversed so
sometimes
almost every sentence is sort of
reversed but sometimes it has to be even
even a whole a whole paragraph has to be
kind of
shuffled around
um
but um
colloquialisms uh that don't exist
there's lots of words in japanese that
don't exist in english and vice versa uh
and you have to really take
extra time on those um
yeah i mean they're heavily context
dependent i would say you just sort of
you sort of write something that you
feel would be true for the character uh
interesting or the situation in in that
instance really i think that's my
general rule of thumb that makes sense
yeah you just get to know the characters
rather than
worrying about the exact translation do
you ever look at them like they're two
different characters from the japanese
version to the english version
or is it like make sure you're super
that was that
i i try to i try to
uh stay totally true to the character
but not be
hung up on specific words so
if something needs to be localized and
adjusted to to be true to the character
that's
what that's kind of my goal um
if we had a very
unique
a very unique character that just
for some you know probably like a
political correct reason in most cases
if there's some unique character that
really has to be changed then you you
might have to rewrite i haven't really i
don't think i've really done this but
you would you might have to rewrite it
as almost a new character but almost
every
yeah every all the characters that i
recall are a reflection of the original
creator's intent
and it's the same person even even even
when it's speaking two different
languages i imagine you'd say the same
thing ian
oh yeah absolutely um
just to add in terms of unexpected
things the the big thing that i've
really learned about over the year is uh
sarcasm and snark uh often you can you
think that uh a character can can be
quite cheeky and
[Music]
uh honestly in the west like uh
we we generally quite like cheeky
characters um some of the most popular
ones are the ones who sort of can be
sort of just sort of gently teasing
toward the player um
but often in japan this does not go over
the way you would think so um
it's just a really interesting pitfall
in terms of like
of of what the reception will be from
from the the player hmm i guess that's
that's an interesting challenge if like
you're trying to make sure that a
character is endearing
or really likable that even that has to
be written differently
for that reception to occur
yeah yeah hmm i never would have thought
about that either
there you go a lot of new things every
day um
yeah it's so translation is um more of
an art than a science yeah and
people don't
they don't
i think
people don't really
um think of this or want to admit it but
you're going to get a different
translation if something's complex like
an entire book you're going to get a
very different feel from translator a
and translator b
um
and in some in some in some spots in the
book you might get very significant
differences where where a little nugget
of philosophy or something might just
be kind of rephrased so much that you
could argue that it's really changed
quite a lot
um can i just jump in for a moment and
say it's actually really interesting uh
when you're working collaboratively with
other translators um because like as
ryan says you know translation is is
definitely an art all you're doing is is
you're taking a target and you're
filtering it through your own brain and
that's gonna you know that filtering
mechanism is based on your entire life
inherently right up to that point
exactly um
but an interesting thing is um you know
uh sometimes when you're working on a
project um
different people get sent you know
different portions of text but maybe
there's some overlapping ideas or
you know even like repeated
lines in certain instances like uh
and it's interesting
when those translations are different
but also sometimes when they're the same
you're like ah
you know
do you guys um again don't answer this
if you don't want to but you know if
you're working on something from soft do
you make sure to just read over each
other's work
oh we have the consistency of each
other's work yeah yeah oh absolutely
yeah consistency is really important
because you're right that like you could
in theory take a a character um i don't
know if you get like character bios that
are written in japanese and you could
even interpret that differently in
theory so i imagine that you guys have
to work very closely to make sure that
that yeah everything is consistent for
for the whole story going through and
yeah it's not just something you can do
in a vacuum
definitely more complicated yes
one thing about the one thing about
sarcasm um is that i too had a similar
journey to g
as ian where i was you know wanting to
kind of add sarcasm
um to make things interesting
and working with miyazaki uh since demon
souls i discovered uh quite quickly that
that his uh
each of his characters is sort of very
sincere there's there's almost no
sarcasm
in the text um
so
and and kind of part and parcel to that
i feel like the the soul series i feel
like they're actually very wholesome
games
interesting take there's violence there
is violence but as far as like
philosophically um thematically
yeah i i think that i think it's a quite
quite a meaningful exploration of sort
of human condition it's it's they're
good yeah i agree
um ian i was going to ask you the same
question i asked ryan and i'm going to
ask you for a different answer if that's
not too complicated which is uh
any unexpected challenges that you
frequently deal with things that that
are difficult about your job that you
feel like most people on the street
would not guess
so
i would say the biggest one is that uh
video games during development are very
volatile substances
things change constantly um you know
you could be working on any game and
really have a handle on the context when
you're working on a specific translation
but then
uh down the line something about that
has completely changed and
if you're told that the thing has
changed then you can rework it but
sometimes you're not or sometimes uh you
know core concepts get reworked behind
the scenes so
some of the data that you're working
with is a bit out of date so it's it's
just
a struggle to keep
on top of everything especially when
there are so many moving parts and
they're all shifting i think that
probably applies to video game writing
in general i think so do you guys
struggle with uh
i don't know how many people from frog
nation work on fromsoft games but like
being in different time zones and being
remote is that something that has like
been a big challenge
when approaching everything that you
work on
well i broke my biological
clock a long time ago so that'll do it
it may shave some years off my life
work with people in any time zone yeah
it makes sense but i kind of answered my
question
i i'm very lucky i i got the
the good side of the bargain in the uh
because all of the the voice recording
and stuff is done in our time i
basically don't have to change my
regular boring nine to five schedule
yeah which is very nice for me yeah that
sounds convenient um
yeah but i can't even imagine being like
you know working on an international
project
from japan
and then
taking it to the uk and if you're all in
different places it just seems like a
lot to manage on top of everything else
like you said that it's already really
volatile like it's like his fault he
grows up on you know
the lord of the rings and he wants to do
his japanese game in british english for
some reason
to go to london
london 17 times over 20 years yeah what
12 excuse me 12 years well you know
they've obviously been very well
received by english audiences um yeah
and japan as well which is unusual like
both
both regions being so successful that is
unusual yeah i've never i've never asked
if they're popular in japan i've never
even it's really popular in japan
usually it's like
usually
there's all there all these
unique japan market only games you know
it's hard to market to kind of both even
though that's what everyone wants to do
to pay the bills yeah
um or china i was a lot of money in
chinese games
[Laughter]
and the soul series has done is doing
very very well in china no way that's
awesome yeah a lot of global
appreciation there um but a lot of years
of work that went into that obviously
it's not like it was easy um ian what
were you gonna say
who knows
life comes at you fast
um another question i wanted to ask is i
feel like we sort of touched on this
earlier but uh
how does it feel you know speaking of of
these games being globally popular um
when the game finally releases and you
see
the reactions like especially where from
soft games are concerned they're just so
beloved um at this point at least from
my perspective like how does it feel to
see people you know dive into the law
that you had a hand in writing do you
watch the youtube videos do you watch
streams do you do you
really absorb the reactions when uh when
the games come out
no
really
i'm playing the game on the first
few days that makes sense i respect that
yeah so i get to i get to kind of see
what what's going on inside
in there so i can see what fans are are
doing as far as you know the messages
and the and what they're wearing and and
the the the the gestures they're using
you know that's true which is a unique
thing about from soft games uh how about
you yeah um i i try not to go too deep
on the community stuff because uh i i
don't want to take in any undue
influence sure keep myself clean yeah i
guess if you watch those 40 minute long
lore videos
yeah that's an interesting point like a
musician who doesn't uh listen to too
much music
i get it fellow yeah because you could
accidentally be influenced by what
people are saying or people think and
when there's such a spectacle on every
word that you write like
yeah i definitely don't want to get
confused on any points of law sure that
may or may not have been interpreted
correctly so yeah yeah yeah sure yeah um
what do you think is the
most important part of your job
the number one like most important thing
for you to execute on every day
i think uh
being true to um
the atmosphere of the game is is my big
thing
um obviously with the the soul series
that's especially important as they are
quite uniquely placed within the video
game pantheon
um
but i mean
i i guess on a
more technical slightly specific side i
you know i work very hard to make sure
that all the language that goes into the
game is appropriate you know and that's
no matter the project you know you don't
want to be
sort of taking people out the experience
by using sci-fi language in a fantasy
game you know just just things like that
um
that's what i like to do that makes
sense
brian how about you
well
i don't know i don't really
i i only do work because i want because
like because i like it because i want to
i'm always just trying to do i'm just
just i'm just trying to entertain myself
i mean
i
i
i don't care i i i i get it what i mean
is that
is i don't
i don't really view it as work i'm just
like playing around i enjoy this and so
i'm sort of like
you know miyazaki has made a lot of
these games kind of in the image of the
ultimate game that he would want to play
himself and i kind of do the same you
know i just like
want it to be good just i want to be
proud of it myself
i don't care what anybody else says but
but i know the people who really know
quality are gonna like it you know
no honestly i 100 approach that stuff
the same way as like i'm not concerned
about the public because it's impossible
i just want to make a good thing and i
want to think it's good and i want my
teammates to think it's good and that's
it it's like we made a good thing
so like okay
maybe the most important thing is like
for me to just like keep my motivation
up and just like
and like get into the game so i can
enjoy it more and spend more brain power
on it rather than trying to get it off
the desk and
get extra time in on you know polishing
text and making characters better and
yeah i mean it's it's interesting you
talk about um you know wanting to make
it something that you really enjoy so i
think one of the interesting challenges
of like working in games is that like
the text is
it functions it
everything in the game is both
functional and artistic
in what we touch you know and so it's an
interesting balance in
you know
you're really having to preserve uh you
know any any sort of gameplay hints or
illusions that are within the textbook
while trying to make it as as you know
pleasurable to read or hear as possible
you know sure yeah the audience point
about um not doing anything that that
breaks that breaks the wall and like
takes you out of the experience that's
kind of like a big no no you you
definitely don't want it that's that
goes into the category you don't want
things to sound like a translation
because that will remind you that it's
not a world and that it's something that
somebody like us wrote
it's a very good answer um well then off
of that and i feel like we've you know
kind of covered it here but to be
specific sorry my dog has demanded a pat
like i said every now and then she will
walk over and just demand to be patted
i'm like all right well i'm hit us up
um what do you think makes bad
localization
what would you categorize as a failure
in terms of localization well all base
belong to us stuff was not really a
failure because it kind of like
succeeded in a different way
yeah i'm not going to argue with that
um i think
i think there's um i mean like like what
i just mentioned you know
there is a definitely a temptation
sometimes to prioritize aesthetic over
function i think that's an easy trap um
i think what is um
i'm not sure if this is no it's probably
not specific to japanese i think this is
more of a general translation thing but
i think there is a
a temptation
to do sort of um like top to tail
translation
so if you think about what we do as
you know we are looking at sentences and
deconstructing them looking at all the
parts and trying to reconstruct them
in english as um
you know efficiently and nicely as
possible but
well i suppose japanese in particular is
a very compact language you can really
say a lot with with very little and so
there's a temptation to sort of like
try and put in the english
absolutely every single like nook and
cranny of nuance that you can find
um
and this can often lead to sort of like
unwieldy clunky translations stuff that
does sound very unnatural as you're
trying to show maybe to your editor that
you really understood the source and you
know you know no detail escaped my
notice here um i think a lot of the
times in english you have to rely a lot
on
like inference
sort of naturally uh push the same ideas
but
you know try it try and write in a way
that people will understand what's going
on but without having to have it
explicitly laid out um
that's a very using every part challenge
i did live with the japanese girl once
who had mentioned to me that english
doesn't have words for half of the
things that she would want to say she
had said that she was like there are so
many things that i want to say that i
can't say without speaking for a long
time and i guess that's what you're
touching on is that there is
more nuance potentially in japanese that
we don't have in english
well i don't think it's you know new
ones that we can't have it's just
different things get expressed in
different ways and
you know when you're just trying to
unpack and repack things um
you know
it's it's the little bits that are
always hardest to stuff back in in a
neat way into the box you know
yeah for sure uh how about you ryan what
do you think makes bad localization
well i mean
if if it's not entertaining it's a
failure sure
i mean
if something
i mean god i mean if
if you have characters speaking that you
know not i mean it's just like with the
drama in in your native language if you
have characters speaking that are not
convincing or endearing or you know
don't ring true or
um sound good
that's a bit of a failure
if it sounds like a translation
you
should probably find somebody else
it's
goes back to the client education thing
you know if clients knew how bad some
translations were they would probably
realize that they
um should find able people
but it's sort of a catch-22 a client is
hiring people because they don't know
what quality is
and so it's difficult for them to select
people
um they might get somebody who um
isn't uh is enabled do you feel like
there are any common mistakes that you
see
no we only work with really good people
being each other naturally
i'm not sure about common mistakes i
mean there's
there are
overly literal translations
yep um
where
they're not incorrect um
they're
they demonstrate an understanding but
they but they they could be
they could be corrected by with
by a good editor you know they could be
um streamlined a bit by good editor and
then it'll be fine
but you don't you know you don't want it
to be
you can't have
sentences or dialogue being you know
really clunky yeah
it has to
it has to flow and uh and then of course
um keeping character
uh a character voice intact is is
important and not easy you kind of have
to have a writer's
some writing skill to do that
i feel like this is uh just from talking
to the two of you like a lot more of a
puzzle than i feel like i expected like
you know i obviously knew
that it's not just direct translations
but i feel like there are a lot more
things at play than i would have
expected and i imagine that yeah you
have to get just as engrossed
uh as any other member of the dev team
in in everything that's happening to
make sure you're doing it correctly and
it sounds like a lot of pressure is all
i'm saying
you're clearly doing a great job
yeah nobody looks closely at these games
well i've had to
write a lot of different voices you know
i've one of the things that i have um
difficulty with is is trying to write
really good
female characters because i mean i mean
i can write
i feel like i can decently write
women's voices
uh but it's basically my exposure to
like
pop culture and it's a bunch of data
that's in my head it's not it's not my
own language it's not even close to my
own language so it takes a lot of work
to make convincing
female character uh i can't remember my
personality type every but everyone has
a weakness i think is the thing and like
i know that from my writer's team is
everybody has things that they're good
at and things that they can't do as well
like i can't right very true i just
can't do this oh this is that's one of
the one that's one of the ones that i've
heard quite a lot is is is a
and it might not just be romance i've
heard of i have different writer friends
and some of them
will like
go into a character's psyche and do like
really deep kind of emotional kind of
like
stuff that can scare you or that's
really really like
revealing or
makes you really vulnerable
and other writers who just like they're
just like no i don't like that
i'm going to stick to plot points and
like motivations and more clear-cut
stuff and that's that's what makes my
stories good and they do a great job of
doing those kind of stories a very
different kind of feel for those two
types of writers yeah and i think that's
a benefit to having a team is the stuff
that i can't do
other people can and the stuff that they
can't do as well i can so like if yeah
if we would have romance i'd be like i'm
not gonna take that like i know i can't
do it but there are things that i can do
and it would be the same i imagine as
your job you know if you can't uh
confidently write female characters
there's something that you can do that
other people can't confidently do that
that i think you know is is one of the
coolest parts about working with the
team of creatives in my opinion it's
everybody
we've had so many different types of
characters you know have old gruff guys
or we'll have people of different class
and people who are very
aristocratic and ian
takes care of the aristocratic people
i am not an aristocrat
you're a good imitator i i do enjoy the
like the
the ticks
yeah of those kind of characters yeah
they're very fun to write i mean that
probably lines up with what you studied
do i imagine yeah exactly i mean you
know
there's there's a lot of great sort of
like bumble aristocrats in uh
in the history of british entertainment
you know it's true
it would be weird if the brit weren't
writing them actually
[Laughter]
yeah no everyone has their strengths and
it's yeah like i said a cool part of
working with with a team of creatives
and i think definitely part of like
probably growing as a writer over the
period of your careers is like knowing
what you're the best at and knowing what
you really can do and like showing
everyone else that you can do and it's
like it's a fun part of the job but also
getting better at the stuff that you
suck at because it can be really easy to
dig your heels in and be like i'm just
not gonna ever do this which is what i'm
at right now with romance
i need to get past that at some point
and hopefully i will because right now
i'd be like i'm sure you can find a way
i have to i guess i've been writing for
10 years now and i've been in triple a
for two
but it's like at some point i'm gonna
have to someone's gonna be like you
gotta do it i'm gonna have to figure it
out i'm just like trying to
avoid it still yeah i mean romance is is
definitely difficult you have to really
tap into a place of earnestness and
vulnerability that can feel very awkward
to put on the page yeah
i really like sibling relationships i
like best friendships i think i probably
like sibling relationships actually um
but the minute somebody has to fall in
love i'm like i don't know how they get
from there to there i don't
how does this work but obviously you
know everyone's just pulling from their
own personal experiences and
that's the cool thing about making a
story that a lot of people enjoy um for
my final question i guess is there
anything else that you guys would like
to share do you have any other tidbits
that you
want to use this time what about what
about you alana
let's take your
at least maybe the last two years what's
an unexpected challenge for you
i would say
i
uh i'm gonna try and phrase it also
around
nda's same secrecy as you i get it
um you go back further if you have to
well it would be yeah i guess i've
written on multiple games at this point
and i i would say a consistent thing is
similar to what
ian said earlier about
games changing all the time and and
having to be very adaptable
in a way
that
you know when i was writing books when i
was 10 i never really had to worry about
i didn't have to worry about other
people changing things and having to you
know service the needs of a gameplay
team or an animation team
and and just shift things based on
those changes um
and that's something yeah when you write
solo is a very different experience but
when you're working on a video game uh
any of them that i've that i've worked
on you know there was uh something that
that
i worked on that i did not have to write
very much um and it ended up being that
they were like write as much as you want
no word limit we just need you to write
this section so i wrote it and then it
ended up being that there was a time
limit and so i had to condense the the
thing that they approved and the call
that they approved but they were like it
has to be now within this amount of
words and that became very difficult uh
because it had to be also timed up with
things that were happening trying to
speak about this fakely very timing
based writing that i had to do
um i think what you're touching on too
is is another thing that's actually
really important about writing and james
in general which is that you just can't
get too attached to things because it is
so volatile you just have to say be like
well okay maybe one day i can probably
recycle a little bit of that but it's
gone yeah and you just have to service
the needs of other departments in a way
that you know i didn't have to do when i
was a reporter um and i didn't know when
i was writing books it's it's just so
collaborative in a way that i find very
very rewarding but it is definitely
challenging and you're right like
i definitely went into writing games
being like if i have to cut something i
don't care um
but i think that probably comes from
being a journalist where you have to cut
stuff all the time to finish the page
you know i started out in magazines so
you're already ready for it yeah yeah
but i feel like for some people when
they start out it's probably hard to be
like oh i have to cut this entire thing
but i pulled my whole soul into that and
i'm just like get rid of it i just want
to make something good i don't care you
kill him whatever it's fine yeah you
really have to have that attitude i
think so too which is working out okay
so far but yeah you definitely can get
attached to things that can be cut like
that had happened to me um with one of
the first games that i wrote on which
was just for a game jam like it was
something really simple that even in
that 48 hours i was like i don't want to
cut that no
yeah you just get used to it but no i
feel like it's a very rewarding thing to
do and yeah i'm very glad to have
started this podcast to chat to people
like the two of you obviously try to
give people advice but also just like a
little bit of insight into
how it works because i feel like things
are way more complicated than everybody
expects in every facet including again
i've just learned a bunch of stuff about
localization that i had
absolutely no idea about before today
um
so thank you guys for for talking to me
i appreciate it absolutely well thanks
very much for having us you make great
games
um thank you did you want to ryan i know
you've worked on a bunch of stuff other
than fromsoft
yes what else have you worked on i have
i just want you to say it
um well like my first job was dragon
warrior seven
uh i worked on the team that did shenmue
two which got like
cancelled after we translated and then
they brought it back later so i think
weird the text got out there
um
uh
what else uh patapon was a great that's
what i was looking for
love the patapons they're so cute yeah
so cute um
a lot of good stuff basically
thank you thank you yeah
good i mean all all around i've just
done
some stuff is unknown but uh i i won't
mention that
cool well um
is there anything that you guys are
working on right now that you want to
direct people to like anything you want
to promote basically or otherwise where
can people find you
well i just i feel responsible for like
answering this question of how to how
how will people get started if they want
to translate video games or
do something related to that um
well you have to get your chops you just
got to learn a lot of japanese um
[Music]
i was confident that that bit's kind of
unavoidable you want to get into
japanese yeah i mean yeah
i mean i mean i mean
like for me i was able to be confident
uh
uh standing next to more experienced
translators because i just absorbed so
much um yeah
anime and comics that i was like i had
this the one thing i was confident about
was colloquialism it was it was speech i
mean there were a lot of translators who
were very good who were quite technical
uh very good who
would get stumped by some
very common phrases that come up
if you read
uh immature comics a lot you know i
think
um a lot of funny like really everyday
phrases that come up in in in
in with these conversations with these
fantasy characters that people don't
ever say in kind of real life it's just
too over the top and stuff and
so
i was just putting your hours in really
for for the skills yeah it's actually
kind of an unusual thing for a lot of
other fields is really needing to absorb
a lot of pop culture
you have to really understand things
culturally like you touched on briefly
earlier like political correctness
completely different in both countries
completely different for both cultures
so what does that adaptation look like
you have to know very well what that is
and it's just absorbing a hell of a lot
of
pop culture that seems like a good step
one what's step two and
well i mean
if you can figure out a way
to finagle yourself to be in japan you
know that's going to be really big i
mean being in japan you just are
constantly learning japanese and i mean
so many
job opportunities in this field are
going to be you demonstrating your
japanese by talking to somebody who
needs a translation and who has an
opening and who will ask you to do it
this weekend starting now and if you can
get that done then that could open doors
quite easily so in japan there is a lot
of demand for
translators all the time
there is still there still remains
uh
demand there's there's still not enough
people who do really good work so if you
if you really work out your japanese and
as ian said um you need to
keep up your english writing skills yeah
as as well because that's going to be
your final output and that's going to
what's going to go to the consumer and
really count
but if you're in japan and you know what
you're doing that you you can certainly
find uh work especially in translation
in general if you open it up to more
than games um
but uh there there is work in games and
pop culture related fields for sure
um i feel like you gotta get solid
advice
yeah
um
ian did you have any closing comments
anything i would like to add
uh i think i've said i think i've said
probably everything that i can i don't
really do social media or anything like
that so i'm good for you very quiet
humble translator
yeah so neither of you are on twitter
because if you are i'll send i'll put a
link in the description if you want me
to to share accounts or anything but i
don't think i saw either of you on no no
it's not sadly
you're making the right call
you've done good work i mean i have like
i have an account but i don't use it so
it's all right okay
um well thank you guys so much for
joining me i appreciate you uh it was a
very very interesting chat and thank you
everybody for watching i will see you
guys next time
thank you bye
[Music]
do
[Music]
you